all right we are nearing the end of a
fantastic day as far as I'm concerned
I've learned stuff and we have one
speaker left who is I'm excited to hear
it's Kitty Young she is a are you ready
for this list a physicist an artist a
maker a fashion designer and a musician
that's pretty heavy all that stuff she's
based in Silicon Valley right here she's
a creative technology at technologists
I'm sorry I'm getting a lot of T on my
what am I doing here it's my necklace
really oh well
Beauty before function she's a manager
of the garage and Microsoft which is a
really cool organization so her
background is in Natural Sciences from
the University of Cambridge and she has
a PhD in physics applied physics from
Harvard but she's kept her artistic
flame alive through art and music and
really loves that side of it too so
after she conducted research at Intel
for a while she says she discovered how
to put all of this together integrating
art and design with Science and
Technology which is a wonderful
combination so I'll let her tell you how
that happened
and how her work now focuses on
cutting-edge technologies like Garmin
design and manufacturing processing
quantum computing in education
yeah quantum computing education she's
gonna take us on a journey to it qug a
geeky guy I had to look that up and I
still couldn't explain it to you which
is why Kitty is going to come and do
that right now Kitty young welcome
[Applause]
hey everyone thank you for staying here
for the very last talk just to a show of
hands here how many of you do like
Natural Sciences physics chemistry type
of things and how many of you are doing
more practical like computer science
yeah and what about the rest like art
design anything I was like marketing
great so I will be talking to you about
my journey combining many different
disciplines together so I work at
Microsoft I manage the garage garage is
a very interesting place it's like a
internal startup and we support internal
startups is the platform for employee
led innovations so any employee with
good ideas they can come to the garage
build prototypes we have ways to help
them go all the way into the market so
Gretchen actually mentioned one of our
garage projects in the morning is the
farm beat if you go to our garage
website you will see all kinds of
projects that's already in the market
and it's all employee generated so that
that's a business slide is basically
showing you that the garage is a program
that's engaged with our employees with
our business teams and our ecosystem so
we work with universities and we have
internship program and we run hackathons
the garage runs the biggest private
hackathon in the world last year we have
23,000 people participating or employees
from Microsoft and we have thousands of
projects submitted so we usually take
close look at the projects and find good
ones that we can help them go forward
well I'm an employee at Microsoft so
it's a platform for employee line
innovations to pursue their passions I
have my passions too so for me I love
science engineering technology but at
the same time I love
Art and Design if you ask anyone in
industry it's very difficult to combine
different disciplines together usually
they're putting put you in a box and
that's you do one thing until you retire
but there's a lot of other opportunities
and you have to take your chance and
create opportunities for yourself so to
me science and are actually not very
different they use similar kind of
methodologies they pursue the things
people do not know have not yet done and
they inspire the middle engineering and
design so in the very interface that's
where you can create useful products for
people you can create useful things to
give you some examples of my projects as
one of my work using machine learning
basically embedding a chip in the dress
that can detect your hand motion you can
train the chip to remember your gesture
so after the training every time you
wave your hand in the correct way a
correct constellation will show up on
the dress and it is also using my
graphic novel a page from a graphic
novel the scientist and her robot
looking into the telescope and in the
sky area it calls the constellations to
show up so I'm demoing the training
process after you train them the neurons
you can then call the constellations and
embedded for translations using the LEDs
that's signal you probably recognize
some of these and I have Big Dipper
Cassiopeia and Orion
this was actually project build on the
in Taos curat chip and that actually is
the only physical demo that shows you
how to use these
pattern matching engine at the same time
I also run a continent computing study
group in our Silicon Valley garage so
you probably hear about of news about
common computing in the news they
usually don't go beyond superposition
and entanglement there's not much the
news articles talk about and rarely do
people sit down and study the math and
understand the subject what is really
all about and if you really want to
learn you have those textbooks but if
you don't have a degree in Natural
Science is usually very hard to pick up
so in order to train people who do not
have a quantum computing background you
really have to have some methodology
some grounded material to get people to
understand it from concept step by step
so I started this this group in our
office to train our employees and
everyone really enjoys it because it's
like a new area that they feel
passionate about and they want to
educate themselves on something new take
a new challenge and also to have the
opportunity to perhaps go into this area
if they want to in the future this is
also build on my my physics background
and this is a super exciting combination
that in my day job I can do both science
and art then I know that this is
something that I would be doing now I
had no idea so when I was a student I
thought that I would just become a
scientist and live happily ever after
but life is much more complex there's a
lot of challenges a lot of surprises but
at the same time many opportunities I
have to go back in time a little bit too
tell you my previous experiences I
really all what I do now to my study of
physics physics let me have a holistic
picture of how the world works including
how the universe works and understand
have an understanding about humanity I
was born in the northern part of China
and then when I was seeing primary
school moved to Hong Kong and Shenzhen
some of you may know that the very
developed technologically advanced
region in China I really enjoy reading
about science when I was a kid I was
really inspired by the Stars and the
universe and the ocean and animals and
everything but at the same time I also
wanted to be a musician or artist I had
all these other intellectual dreams as
well but so I started thinking how do I
contribute back to the society now I
found science to be the most direct way
and I thought if I became scientist I
can probably still do art but if I did
art it might be harder to to still do
research so that's I was a little greedy
so I decided to I wanted to do all of
them so I chose to focus on science so I
really started my professional journey
in University of Cambridge I did my
undergrad and master's degrees there at
the same time I started working in
Cavendish lab since the first year of my
undergrad so that's extracurricular I
found a lab in Cavendish and started
working there as a student researcher
since my first year so I did condensed
matter physics the group is called
quantum matters so we study the quantum
property of materials uni so cool
materials down to really really low
temperature and measure
is quantum properties like capacitance
resistance you need to cool them down in
something called the illusion
refrigerator is a super powerful fridge
that can cool your materials down to 4k
using liquid helium and then additional
phase transition can let the environment
to cool even down to sub Kelvin that's
how you can really measure quantum
properties of my hero's noise is always
a problem to showed our measurement so
we need to get rid of noise and because
this is super cutting edge research we
even had to make those equipment parts
ourselves in the workshop so there are
learn how to use the the lathe use the
different components to create to shred
make parts from metal that was very
important experience for me later on as
a maker and I wanted to do more applied
science
so in Cavendish it was more fundamental
so I wanted to see how I can apply my
knowledge into actual products so I
decided to pursue my PhD and very likely
going to Harvard School of Engineering
and Applied Sciences there are pursued
Applied Physics my lab invented a new
type of electronics called plasmonics
circuits any of you heard of plasmonics
or plasma oh yeah a couple of you great
so plasmonics are a plasmatic waves are
waves that are generated in electron
systems if you have a bunch of electrons
put together you can create a wave they
have collective interactions so the wave
can propagate in your material you can
confine the electron into two dimension
because of the dimensionality you can
give the material interesting properties
that you wouldn't see in 3d 3d
so because of the this properties we
could confine them onto the chips create
circuit structures on the chip and guy
the wave through the chip and to
manipulate the wave so you can propagate
information that way and create
structures that can manipulate the wave
to get the effect that you want so I
learned a lot in the career room so
basically I did things from scratch
coming up with a system theoretically
prove it and simulated it and if the
simulation works out I will go into the
clear room and fabricate the materials
myself using a beam or photolithography
and then design the experiment measure
them then publish paper all the whole
process because of the skills that I
learned in grade school was applicable
for silicon photonics so I got into
Intel after I graduated silicon
photonics is very similar to plasmonics
so instead of using plasma waves this is
using light wave you can confine light
unto two-dimensional chips and
manipulate the light propagation where
this is use is in the data centers so we
do not touch the Dana Center every day
but we if we're using it all the time
whenever you connect to the internet
with your phone with a computer you're
using data center and in theaters and
other memory racks of servers between
the servers you use optical fiber to
connect the servers but between the
optical fiber and the servers you need
an interconnect that can convert it
electrical signal and optical signal so
that's what we were doing using silicon
photonics is the interconnect that would
that would help you send light and
manipulate light and is for
infrastructure for data center telecom
data centers optical communication I
thought that I will be working on this
for a long time as a research scientist
this is super fun and very useful until
I discovered something surprisingly
interesting
are you familiar with open source
hardware like Arduino the port's that
you can program you can put sensors and
components on the microcontrollers so
enjoy at that time was making these
chips that would go on to those
microcontroller boards so I work on the
Drule module and the the Curie module so
those are kind of super small
microcontrollers and mini computers you
can embed it into all kinds of things so
you can you can create your own things
like robots or drones or IOT devices and
for me I really like design garments so
I embedded that into fashion design to
give you an example that's using
accelerometer again to detect our motion
so it changes the color on the optical
fibers I also made these kind of glasses
they can communicate through bluetooth
so they'd come there synced and can
change from opt that can change from
transparent to opaque at the same time
so imagine you're wearing one of these
glasses on the street and you see a
stranger approaching you're worried
similar glasses so you may have very
similar fashion taste if your heart
rates matches maybe you can change check
each other out so you flip from
excellent glasses to transparent you can
see the eyes so this is actually
exploration for me to provoke human to
human interaction using technology so
instead of human-computer interaction I
wanted to see if we can create things
that would encourage human communication
with the aid of technology just like if
you have dogs if you your dogs play
together and you start talking and also
play with other types of open-source
hardware so Intel had those modules but
there are other vendors other brands
that create all kinds of small chips
that you can embed into
there are ones that are specifically
designed for fashion design you can you
can sew them using conductive thread and
I learned to play with them and use all
kinds of inputs and output to create all
kinds of interesting things so the
democratization of hardware really
helped creatives to get their hands on
technology they can apply those in all
kinds of industries so outside of work I
created more garments this one uses
brain signal to control the the colors
and patterns on the dress the hazard is
from a company called bring code so you
can sense the intensity of your thought
and you said to through Wi-Fi you can
control the the chip on the dress I have
this earlier version that is not using
input it's just hard coded color change
but all of these are using my my
paintings on the fabric this is called
the chaotic earth in a peaceful universe
I also had ones that had mechanic
motions this one has like wings that can
move and falling leaves simulated by the
randomly blinking LEDs and the last one
this is a 3d dandelion because my
painting is the dandelion and I also had
this painting of Jupiter you can rotate
the storm of Jupiter by rotating the
satellite I on the shirt these are
actually just background backstage
recording of San Francisco Fashion Week
in 2016 so I designed twelve pieces half
of them had electronics technology in
embedded the other half were multi ways
and all of them had my paintings on the
designs and the theme of that that
fashion show is called tag drives
fashion
I really think tag is the future of
fashion and it's the future of all
traditional industries
at the same time we also used the Intel
Architecture to create something useful
I actually form a start-up inside our
company with three other friends from
different groups we had this little
startup team that we build wearable
devices for health and safety and we won
a competition and also God's traction
and interest from our internal VVC
founding and we filed a patent
everything was going really well and I
was learning a lot about startups then
inside a big company you can also learn
about startups and you can gain
experience you can understand how that
it's like to actually build a startup
well everything was going in the right
direction
my happiness didn't last very long yet I
decided not to pursue the make her
direction we're about directions so the
product cut that actually happens that
happens in companies sometimes the upper
management they would make decisions
that you may not agree with and this was
really hard broken because open source
hardware is also about education so it
was really said that we decided not to
pursue this direction so I went back to
silicon photonics I could do my job very
well I liked it and is useful but then I
realized something take a look at this
icky guy graph and identify yourself see
where you lie in which region your life
so for me I was just a little bit below
geeky guy so I was missing something
that I love I felt that I was using only
half of my brain not the other half
because I had a taste of my dream job
and that was gone so I was not satisfied
anymore
if that doesn't combine with my
profession and and love together but I
realized that products can be cut groups
can be reorge
but no one can take away what I love to
do if the environment doesn't allow me
to do what I want I can Stu do it I will
keep doing that I got a lot of support
from the maker community my work was
noticed I kept on doing more designs and
I also explore different types of
technology this one is using 3d printing
3d printing can be considered as one of
the most mature new technologies you
anyone now can buy or 3d printer not for
very much money or you can use services
to get your design submitted and and
print it out so through projects like
this I was trying to figure out how I
can scale my ideas how can i reproduce
is it possible to make multiples of
these designs so I learned how to do 3d
design this is fusion 360 and SolidWorks
and a lot of menu work still I had these
parts printed and had to sew these on
two fabrics through this process I was
trying to figure out if I can convert
what I was making by hands into
something a factory can reproduce so it
didn't take very long for my work to be
noticed by Microsoft and I was then
hired by the garage is really a very
helpful environment to support employee
to pursue your passions this one was my
first build in the garage is using our
3d printer
I made this holder for a solar panel
this you can walk outside and to charge
your phone at the same time I actually
walk around he make her fair for whole
day and my phone ran out of battery I
put like the rain it was really useful
and most of the solar powered jackets
that you can find in the market
having the solar panel vertical but you
few needs enough sunlight you need to
have this angle so I thought that that
would look ridiculous but then I may as
well make it avant-garde so I just
designed this hole at this backpack
holder that's based on the pattern on
the fabric this I wanted also to show
that this solar panel is not designed
for fashion it's just a portable panel
you can carry when you go out but if
with clever design you can embed it into
fashion design so that goes with any
hardware any technology I can design it
into something wearable the eye
opportunities open up I got people
sending me their hardware and their
materials this is from my friend who
works at sati Institute he has a company
called made of Mars and he works on Mars
exploration they want to use this
material from volcanic rocks to produce
daily appliances and items these are
volcanic rocks that upholding to fiber
and then weave into fabrics they usually
use for very heavy duty industrial
applications are wrapping tubes
high-temperature applications but then
they want to see if it is possible to
design something fashionable because
this much hero is abundant is everywhere
on Mars so you can find on earth in
places like Iceland or Hawaii
but if we learn how to handle this
material on earth once humans do leave
to to Mars we can know how to build
things using the raw materials there and
at the same time I took this as a design
challenge but then I thought when and
why should we ever go to Mars is it
because the earth environment is
terrible is it because the pollution is
too bad that we can no longer live on
earth
so I started put to as a concept I put a
optical touch sensor in the front so you
can detect the air quality
using a Adafruit circuit playground it
has the different sensors including
temperature sensor and buzzer and LEDs I
use it to detect the temperature and the
air quality and the sound and the color
of the LEDs can give warnings when
something goes wrong so this is a
concept to warm people even that we are
doing exploration in outer space in our
solar system we should still take care
of the earth environment
so this warns you about global warming
and pollution this is my latest build
using the EKG heart rate monitor that
can detect my heart rate I put the
electrodes on three different parts on
my body and they can link the leds
according the heart to the heart rate
you can see the EKG graph on the photo I
wanted to show people that for fitness
and health devices we don't have to
stuck on the wrist there's enough
products that that just accessories why
can't we explore putting that into our
beautiful clothing and daily wear I had
a very good education I really enjoyed
my past experiences things that are
learning school but there are things
that I only learned after I started
working in industry so first thing here
is the environment as I mentioned
earlier you get hired for your skill
sets and sometimes you get put into a
box that if you have great ideas
creative ideas that may not align with
your business group if the environment
doesn't support you you you will find it
very difficult to pursue so having the
environment that allows you to expand
your imagination is very important I am
very lucky to be in such in
and as a earlier older generation of
Millennials I can relate to a lot of
younger talents that they they are so
interdisciplinary they learn all kinds
of different subjects but if we as an
established industry do not provide such
growth environment people are gonna be
unhappy at their jobs so we have to
change some current structures in
establish industry to allow young
talents to grow and give them
opportunities the other thing I realized
was scaling a lot of things that we did
in the labs our profile concepts we we
build things in the lab we do
experiments but then we really need 10
to 20 years to scale it to make things
that we invent in the labs into a real
product or something that's really
useful you need hundreds of engineers to
work on and one thing I think would be
helpful is doing open source so when I
create my projects I would publish them
all open-source platforms so anyone can
learn how to build something similar I
actually learned a lot from the maker
community and I wanted to contribute
back by sharing what I know about the
materials and the components you can
also find all of these projects online
on the open-source platforms and build
something that you like maybe not in
fashion maybe being something else but
not all of my friends make her not
everyone's make her I go people ask how
do I actually buy your things bio
designs so out of curiosity I was
thinking how does it take to actually
produce some of my design to real
garments that can be so in the market so
I managed to produce three designs in
the market last year they all have my
paintings on them with this one using a
lenticular piece that will change from a
Eclipse to a full moon
that's also my painting but then you
asked where's that where's the electrons
where's the hi-tech turnout is not that
easy
turn out that the industry is actually
not developed enough to produce such
inventions so this was a design that I
made for in town two years ago it's just
a t-shirt with a wearable robot and some
soft electronics circuit on the fabric
turned out that the robots are much
easier to produce so anywhere with
hardware background it's very easy to
get that done but then these soft part
is actually more difficult we had this I
basically build this prototype by hand
how to hand Stitch the conductive thread
onto the fabric if we want some factory
to make this we couldn't quite find good
places to do it and you ventually we
could find some makerspace to help us
but that will cause us a hundred dollars
per t-shirt so that's not really
acceptable that made me realize the
problem in the industry that actually
some of our ideas that we have now is
not quite achievable it goes around in
this negative cycle that's impeding us
to pursue our designs so creative
designers they can make things by hand
very easily they can do whatever
anything that they they can build upper
hand but then they really rely on
manufacturers to scale it to produce
products but manufacturers they refuse
to do it until they see market they have
to see that what they are making can
make money but mass population would not
generate the mound they would not show
market until they see some existing
product that's already in the market so
this is really backward and if then also
shows a couple of problems as in the
manufacturing chain so there's not
enough automation and if we want to put
tag in garments that's currently very
difficult and there's also not enough
made-to-order that's actually one of the
major problems in fashion is industry so
fashion designer
like stools I can attest by doing
different artistic endeavors whose
really advanced the arts so music the
invention of instruments can help
musician express their emotions their
feelings the invention of the modern
piano really helped Beethoven start
writing a different general of music
from classical to romantic and I was
painting my graphics on the computer
about 10 years ago I started doing that
that's because of the invention of these
tablets that you can plug into a
computer and start drawing digitally so
then I could print my digital files or
any surfaces including different kinds
of fabrics the technology allowed us to
achieve our idea much much easily and
faster the existence of 3d design
software can allow us to build 3d
printed structures without going into
sculpture so fashion design is left
behind I wanted to understand why how we
make things make garments the same way
as how we make electronics with the
background of chip design and
manufacturing I could see a lot of
parallel in those two manufacturing
processes we always start with 2d design
we represent our different materials and
different layers of things using 2d
layouts the upper one is what we would
draw to represent the circuit and we
send this file to a cleanroom a foundry
we have a couple of Engineers to help
but most mostly is fire driven and
automatic the machines know how to read
these files and lay out different
materials and then you can produce chips
you cut you can produce the wafers and
you cut them into chips and then solder
them onto PCB boards
the PCP bar is also again design file
driven as long as you can draw these 2d
files you can get things produced
easily and then you can package the
packaging is also by design by those
files Wow four garments you also start
with a design representing a 3d
structure in 2d you draw out the
patterns and then you give this to
pattern makers but then in this process
it goes back and forth so many times
first time the usually fit is wrong
there are a lot of human error in it and
you have to correct the fit and then the
second time the fabric is wrong because
the first time they don't use the actual
fabric so if you change the fabric there
will be mistake the third time when
those things are corrected is missing
details it's missing buttons and you
already would tell them at the very
beginning you show them the design but
still many many back and forth a lot of
exchanges and waste of time and effort
is not this as streamlined and efficient
as the electronic manufacturing and
eventually you can get your design your
prototype into a factory and people
working in terrible conditions
eventually you produce things like that
that's super cheap and not creative no
one wants to buy them you go discounted
sounds I still in the shop is lying
there no one wants them guess what
eventually those goods gets burned we
actually produced a lot of waste and
pollution in garment industry
so just by you can just search online
the pollution generated in karma
industry is well understood and one of
the problem is the overproduction why do
we need to make so many pieces of
clothes if Noah wants them and that's
the problem that I really want to solve
that's where I can see how technology
can help resolve this issue right now
I've showed the collaboration between
research things that you invent
from research centers in labs you can
make them open-source and creative
people when they get it they can make
things that actually people want you can
make functional things and aesthetic
things and then you use education to to
educate more people younger people in
school educate the market anytime you
introduce anything new into the world
you have to convince more people so this
ecosystem these different communities
they have been working together but what
we are lacking is a way to help
creativity and neat driven manufacturing
right now that's not there that's a very
big problem and is not letting creative
people to achieve their ideas and the
technology has been not available not
democratized for anyone to use for
anyone to produce something from a
initial sketch to a 2d file and then
into an actual government is got a lot
of processes but we can really help this
whole chain of production using all
kinds of technologies in your design you
can have things like 3d avatar of
yourself so you can get your fit before
you you know how the garment looks on
yourself you can use mixed reality
platforms to do that and there's
computer vision that you can apply in
fashion right now a lot of the ideas
have been looking at a picture and then
referring you to existing product and
then recommend what you can buy but what
if we can take a picture of a existing
garment someone on the street that you
really like you take a picture that will
automatically be generated into those 2d
patterns that could be sent into the
factory and get produced much easily so
we shouldn't be making things that over
produced we should only be making things
when someone wants it you can make the
platform the 2d
pattern available for people to choose I
want this kind of color this kind of
bodies this kind of sleeves and I want
my own combination at the factory level
all these files should be driven
automatically and letting people tap
into this manufacturing and they could
produce a lot of similar color similar
bodies and sleeves but then eventually
you have a different combination
according to people's orders so you
shouldn't be produced things on you
someone already orders them already
backed by an order and at the same time
in those processes we can then think
about how do we put those electronics
those microcontrollers functional
electronics into the fabric right now
I showed things that we were using
open-source ports to do but then we
really need to scale it to shrink it
down to very small sizes and make it
flexible make it part of the fabric to
be able to make it comfortable so
there's a lot of problems in the
industry and is really a engineering
problem I feel like this is not this is
a hard thing to do because of all these
different parties in the ecosystem you
have to combine them they're each
individual technology that's out there
but we really need to combine them link
them together to solve this vertical
industry but it's also not that hard
because it's just engineering we just
have to turn a few engineers into
fashion designers so that's what
essentially a platform company would do
we need to empower everybody we need to
empower the creative the designers give
people the technology so they can they
can decide what to use the technology
for and this will help creativity to
drive production rather than profit
driven or volume driven that's producing
many waste and pollution so what I found
out through my journey
is basically knowing what I really like
to do and applying different disciplines
together by the same time scale it to
something bigger to something more
impactful and don't wait for anyone to
give you your dream job if you want to
work on something just go for it
even if your day job is not allowing you
to do it eventually you find your
audience there's also not enough
discussion about later support of
women's development in tech industries
so what if you are going to have a baby
what if you your partner is moving to a
different place there needs to be enough
support to allow a woman to stay in
their industry stay in their field
pursuing their jobs and while staying
with their loved ones it shouldn't be a
either-or to choose between your career
and the family there should be
environments that allow us to pursue all
the things that we treasure in our lives
the environment is very important when
you want to decide your future and also
what we contribute to the society should
be intellectual there's a lot of noise
in social media all those platforms that
we engage every day but we find out that
if we look back into history is the
intellectual value that distilled and
passed down generations we always listen
to the best music read the best
literature from the past the noisy
things in contemporary world would not
pass down what I found very important is
that when we generate our content is
very important to stay intellectual I
sometimes look into our own world like
an alien from outer space
to understand the beautiful and ugly in
our world when we are in our 20s we
probably would look around and trying to
find all kinds of opportunities trying
to get as many experiences as possible
in our 30s we kind of learn how to focus
we find the vertical that we want to
spend the rest of our life but sometimes
people in their 30s some of them become
the most world's most famous bigots and
some people they regret they haven't
become the world's most bigots but what
I'm hoping is that more of us most of us
will stay true to ourselves whenever we
look back deep down into our hearts with
we can find a child inside ourselves
thank you I don't know if there's
question time or anything the things
that I presented or something that I
missed you my presentation yes thank you
for your presentation it was fantastic
to see all your different work and I
really like the chart that you showed
about you kid guy and I'm curious how
often you like revisited that or how
often you go back to looking at it and
making sure that what you're doing
throughout the years was I I think I
only look at it once so far only when I
if I will revisit it it's probably when
I'm not happy so when I'm unhappy I can
look back into their chart and reanalyze
my situation yeah fantastic presentation
thank you
when is your quantum setting study group
is only internal and we hosted
other week usually depends on my
schedule because yeah right now is me
leading it but then through this this
workshops more people are interested so
they volunteer to teach so we are doing
like beginners track we cover those
fundamentals and then we would do some
more difficult algorithms like using the
concept that we learn in actual
programming and also we will invite
external speakers to talk about maybe
hardware experiments that they do to
give us the industrial flavor of the
field we are making some tutorials and
hopefully we can we can share it with
the public in the future but right now
the Q sharp team the Microsoft team they
have publications they have their
different aspects of quantum computing
already on the website so you should
look it up yeah yeah you can feel free
to chat with me during that work thank
you
[Applause]